hello there issue two of fortnite and
marvel's crossover series zero war is
here let's break down what happened and
highlight a few law secrets and hidden
info along the way i shall link issue
one now if you're new here and everyone
else let's do this oh and kodamaru
please and thank you issue two of the
zero one
last time we were sent to find a shard
of the zero point which was ripped off
and taken to reality 616 by galactus
join the live event in chapter 2 season
4. issue 2 begins back on the island as
the avengers led by tony stark have
joined forces with the seven led by the
foundation a power struggle immediately
begins between iron man and the
foundation stark is quick to remind us
what he masterminded last time he was in
reality zero he single-handedly created
millions of battle buses using the zero
point time looping ability and filled
them with enough gamma bombs to send the
literal destroyer of worlds back where
he came from the foundation on the other
hand was stuck in an asteroid during all
this waiting to be freed so maybe tony
does have a point as bullets and
shrapnel fly past their heads the
foundation makes a backhanded compliment
to iron man how did you design such
impressive armor to which iron man
reciprocates they like each other's
technology and suits it's not quite a
bromance just yet but a deal is made on
the battlefield they will be co-leaders
iron man is in charge of earth's
mightiest heroes while the foundation
gives himself the title of commander of
reality zero forces the two shake hands
on this new arrangement
meanwhile there's actually a job to do
while we're here steal a spaceship
captain marvel is the first to get in
there and get out again with the new
tech and we've never seen this before
it's like a hybrid of a ufo and the old
i o airships it looks pretty dapper and
if we know fortnite one day we will ride
this vehicle in game but not right now
the scene ends with iron man telling
everyone that only he can say avengers
assemble and the foundation is like yeah
i'll try to contain my disappointment so
why the heck do they need the ship cast
your mind back to the last issue they
need to get to the moon because up there
is the crash-landed mecca piloted by the
paradigm on board this trip are the
foundation iron man the scientist who's
come to repair the mech and thor and
storm come along too their job is to
change the weather and hopefully stop
everyone from freezing to death no
pressure guys captain marvel is now in
charge on the ground and she says the
iconic line avengers assemble and not to
miss an opportunity the foundation
reminds us i thought you were the only
one to say it and tony admits he's
scared of captain marvel she is quite
terrifying there are now three separate
teams we are following in this story
iron man and co are going to the moon to
save paradigm captain marvel and the
squad on the island are fighting io and
agent jones the imagined and spider-man
who recently recruited wolverine those
chaps are going to wakanda to find the
zero point shard so let's catch up with
them
the wakandans don't recognize spider-man
and our heroes are already in a battle
the second they arrive it includes these
giant panther-like droids who only act
to annoy the imagined and delight
wolverine spider-man seems to be the
only person acting rationally and
prevents jones from murdering innocent
wakandans who are just doing their job
the rpg instead hitting wolverine but
luckily he can regen so it doesn't
bother him too much but he does admit it
still hurts for someone over 200 years
old you'd think jones would be less
gung-ho the two pilots inside the
panther mech are now shown commenting on
what they're seeing saying that
americans are insane before realizing
wolverine is actually canadian the thing
which really interests me here is in the
bottom corner the person who translated
wakandan into english is agent smith
it's obviously a pseudonym but agent
smith in the marvel world was the one
who recruited deadpool in the movies and
in the comic books he played both sides
both for hydra and as a shield agent
hopefully agent smith will have
something more important to do soon
suddenly the wakandan forces are ordered
to stand down by a new character to the
story it's shuri the princess of wakanda
will someday be in fortnite but not
right now so this will be her
replacement in my cutaways spider-man
explains the issues going on on the
island and wolverine vouches for him
long story short shuri welcomes the
quartet to wakanda the shard of the zero
point we are hunting for is given a
slightly different name now a
crystallized fragment it's somewhere
close but the imagined can't find it
exactly because wakanda is filled with
vibranium an ultra strong and durable
metal like no other well except
adamantium the four are taken into a
room filled with vibranium jones is
immediately smitten and asks to take
some home sure he is stern if the
fragment is here you're welcome to it
and only it so how will they find the
fragment in all this vibranium the
answer is right in front of us wolverine
he has a sense of smell like no other
[Music]
he can literally smell the zero point
and the fragment was here recently but
it's been stolen and plot twist the only
thing that can get through wakandan
security is something with the
physiology of a lizard i kid you not the
shard of the zero point has been stolen
by a lizard and it so happens that
killmonger has been training dinosaurs
recently yep this story is is so strange
the next scene opens in the valley of
dinosaurs serpent valley and of course
aliya's favorite dinosaur is here
there's a diplodocus dinosaurs share the
world with us in reality 616. before our
heroes can take in the sights a side is
thrown at jones's head but perfectly
blocked by wolverine would you believe
it it's an army of ninjas they are back
in the story the last time we saw these
guys was back in chapter one we watched
frozen dragon eggs thawing at polar peak
before they were transported to the
volcano and that heat hatched them into
what we call hybrids they follow the
fire deity we call the prisoner who also
hasn't been seen for a long time
although legend has it he's a prisoner
in the i o facility underground just
waiting to be unleashed oh and one more
thing those hybrids can ride raptors
another piece of foreshadowing that soon
will be able to do that in the real game
a battle ensues between the heroes and
the hybrids until one is unmasked
revealing they have lizard features
shuri is shook a human lizard hybrid
stands before them in all the action one
of the hybrids escapes probably because
everyone is distracted by hybrid
superior butt stand aside chunley
spiderman swings over to catch up with
the guy and gets there just in time to
take a bomb blast to the face destroying
all evidence of what these guys were
doing there's no other way to put this
the team had failed the zero point shard
was gone only kidding wolverine can
smell it remember he takes a big whiff
and identifies the scent of a half-man
half-reptile person spider-man then
takes the opportunity to name drop like
he does in every episode so far he tells
us of a super villain named stegron the
dinosaur man and yep it's a legit super
villain in the marvel universe it's
vincent stegron that's spider-man's
third name drop in just two episodes so
far
[Music]
we jump back to the foundation on his
way to the moon to find the mecca
frantically thor and storm are keeping
everyone safe from the weather but it's
no use they crash land on the moon being
unsure how long they can survive up here
they immediately try to find the crushed
mech and it turns out it's easier to
find than you'd think bright pink is
quite easy to spot the mech is missing
an arm it's missing a power core and it
has a ruptured hull yet somehow paradigm
is still alive foundation lifts her from
the wreckage in the final shot of the
episode
so there's a few plot holes we really
should talk about like paradigm if the
mech crashed here in 2019 that means
she's been laying there without food
water or heat for years i have no idea
how she survived i'm sure we'll get told
in the next episode and in that next
episode we'll find out how captain
marvel got on against sloane and how
wolverine's nose found a new enemy to
hunt and hopefully we'll understand how
paradigm survived i'm adam you're
awesome i'll see you next time thank you
to everyone who used my code this month
much appreciated see you for episode
three
[Music]
you